to the monologue where it's time for
the biggest most insane story that no
one is covering because it no longer
serves a use as a phony smear against
political enemies
gotta shorten these titles
so it's 2021 and this monologue is on
the steele dossier like a birthmark this
story never ever goes away is that my
fault no i would much prefer to do
something on joe biden breaking wind at
the climate summit
that breeze was so hot greta thundberg
asked him to stand in front of a
windmill
but look that fart was the only honest
thing to come out of joe since he became
president
too easy who is he don't applaud
no we don't have enough time for the
applause okay
but that's why that story was my first
choice but now unfortunately it's number
two
i'm not beneath anything
and why because now the legacy media is
smothering the dossier story like it's a
bedridden ant with a lot of money
but here we're different
see the dossier hoax is like spending
the holidays with your parents is as
important as it is soul-crushing
because that one false manufactured
story guided nearly everything the media
focused on for over four years and when
we made fun of it the media made fun of
us like we were in denial when in fact
it was them all along so we need to
settle a score and then run that score
up like the harlem globetrotters playing
against the little sisters of the poor
so first a recap the steele dossier was
an anti-trump conspiracy theory funded
by the clinton campaign it became the
number one all things russian smear
buffet all he needed was boris natasha
and a bowl filled with poison borscht
the dossier has been corroborated by the
intelligence community the dossier in
fact is far from bogus i think we're
going to actually have to stop calling
it the infamous dossier
increasingly it's the accurate dossier
the famous dossier which is getting a
lot more credibility now the republican
claim today was that the dossier has
been increasingly discredited
that's not true in terms of the public
record about the dossier in fact it's
quite the opposite ah they have so much
egg on their face their eyeballs need
lipitor
still bigger than watergate though
what we are watching in the trump
presidency is worse than watergate i
keep getting asked are there echoes of
watergate in this and there are we're
also witnessing something we did not see
in watergate which is a meltdown
by a president who was demonstrably
unhinged what we're seeing uh is worse
than watergate
[Music]
poor guy i mean think about it when
watergate was your last success
you'd be bringing it up too
but it's been 50 years almost that's
like me bragging about the time i got a
lego stuck up my nose
that was 50 years ago too but i'm not on
cnn comparing everything to that
okay it was last year but so what
then there's rachel whose brain snapped
in 2016 like a stella doro breadstick
this guy columnist keeps turning up
again and again constantine columnist
constantine kalimnak constantine
kalimnik constantine he's still russian
military intelligence kilimnik a short
man who goes by kostya this guy
constantine kalimnik constantine
kalimnik investigating constantine
kalimnik for espionage this guy
constantine kalimnik is the key that
unlocks that door it seems like it would
have to be
she hadn't been that excited since
supercuts dropped their clipper cut from
28 to 22 dollars
anyway
but anyway the steel dossier was hyped
more than the fox patriot awards at the
villages
i know it you know
but it turns out it was fake
how fake
[Music]
red meat multiple choice test
yeah the dossier was as fake as a
calmly laugh
be our president's teeth
see hillary's smile
d the clinton marriage
and bonus option it's as fake as the
urine cat supplies for her weekly drug
test
it's the first sample they've seen that
was carbonated
now please write down your choice on the
back of a cereal box and mail it to joe
scarborough care of bellevue hospital
now the new indictments coming out from
special counsel john durham are even
crazier by the way what is with this
picture
is this is this the only picture ever
taken of john durham
could he look any more like a german
u-boat commander
the scary thing is that's his sixth
grade class picture
and why isn't he playing the lead in the
life and times of wilford brimley
talk about cocoon you could wrap
yourself in that stash sometimes i
thought about it and if you turn his
head upside down doesn't he look
familiar
all right enough at his expense so the
indictment offers lots of new evidence
revealing the steel's key source
involved a shady guy named igor igor
made false statements to the fbi about
his role in supplying the gossipy smears
to steal steele was that former british
spy who worked for fusion gps he's like
007 if that stood for his iq
so was this the ticking time bomb we
were promised by every blue checker on
twitter from 2016 up to 2020 well it was
indeed a bombshell except it went boom
boom all over them and because of that
the story sinks like a gambino member
wearing cement shoes never to be seen
except on this show
because
gutfeld we care about the truth and
latex goods and also leather we care
about leather and latex goods
mostly
so igor on behalf of hillary helped
plant the lies to fuel the collusion
fairy tale as the fbi fbi also used
steel's work to obtain surveillance
warrants yet as igor confesses it was
all based on booze fueled hearsay from
friends
which is not bad research
that's how i found out that bigfoot had
impregnated the loch ness monster to
give birth to carrot
that's all my
research but then his real source
which was another democratic hack a guy
whose only connection to the kremlin is
the bottle of russian dressing in the
fridge
my wife has more of a connection to
moscow it's the poster of a shirtless
putin above our bed
in other words this whole thing was a
hoax a malicious deception like cat's
extensions
[Laughter]
and much like all the other hoaxes we've
heard the fine people lie the injecting
bleach covington kavanaugh crt doesn't
exist but white supremacy does well i
feel like i just wrote an outline for a
new fox nation series
hosted by diamond and silk
but this dossier smear was designed to
sway an election claiming trump was
under moscow's control because of the
extortive power of blackmail so is the
media admitting to their huge error now
of course not the story is too huge to
admit it being false and that's why the
hugest story on earth must vanish
because it's not simply the media
admitting to being wrong it's admitting
to being fundamentally deluded for over
four years and if there's any guiding
principle to today's legacy journalism
that's it
let's welcome tonight's guest
whenever he hears the word dad he just
assumes someone is trying to talk to him
because he has a lot of kids fox and
friends we can co-host pete hegson
he dresses like the job he wants 1980
standup comedian host of the next
revolution
steve hilton
she's like my laundry he smells nice but
then it ends up on the floor for days
foxy's contributor cat tim
and he always looks down at his fans
because he has no choice he's tall my
massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion iris
how you doing there pete good do great
good good good you enjoy your uh your
weekend with the extra hour always yeah
you were super oh yeah it's a morning
show dream yeah it is it's daylight
savings you get that extra everyone else
hates it i love it yeah cat just sees it
as another hour of black oh i get drunk
all the time yeah
i love drinking
i got it right right yeah you got it
right that's where you were going with
that yes i was yeah i thought yeah all
right surprising i could figure that out
cause all the drugs i'm on
[Laughter]
so pete what does the silence tell you
it tells you that the media always
controls the spigot and they design what
narrative they want or don't want uh of
course they do i mean at this point
we're at the point where
i would say there's more evidence
for the moon landing being faked
more evidence for 9 11 being an inside
job and more evidence for epstein
killing himself
than there is of the russian collusion
interesting really i mean will you step
you step back and look at the evidence
that durham as goofy as you may look is
presenting you've got igor and olga yes
olga's the other source along with uh
this charles dolan right all of which
are now admitting every aspect of it was
hearsay while drunk
or dolan said this is a uh he had a gop
friend who was telling these things then
once pressed he said i don't actually
have a geo a republican friend at all
that told me these things yeah yeah yeah
so as they actually asked them the
question of where they got the
information they admit it yet as as
donald trump said and he's right where's
the where are they going to revoke any
pulitzer's for this no they're not
they're not of course they're not what i
got from you is that so you're saying
you believe the moon landing actually
happened i might
i
do well yeah you think epstein killed
himself
uh
no
i'm saying there's more evidence that he
did than there is that all right trump
colluded with the duality of he was
being sarcastic i was trying i know i'm
just like
no but i i
your your sarcasm about the moon landing
was noted so you do believe it happened
i do which is so naive and silly but we
got to move on
that was the point i was getting at uh
steve this is not i i this is not about
trump this is not a trump story this is
a media story and because we're in the
media we are so quick to move on to
things we're not even talking about
afghanistan that was what a month ago
maybe it's it's the media but also the
way that they're all the establishment i
know that's afraid everyone's oh the
establishment the deep but they are all
the same thing and you've got these
people now i mean look at look at one
aspect of this it's a small aspect but
it was just amazing that how it all fits
together
fiona hill turns up in the middle of
this story remember fiona hill yes she
was like the star witness in the ukraine
impeachment thing and so she shows up in
this story she's the one that introduced
them in the first place she's the one
that introduced the russian to dolan to
whatever you know and like and then she
ends up in the trump white house and
like the whole way that all these people
are just completely connected and now
she's running around as the kind of hero
of the anti-trump yeah resistant this
fanatic she's got a book out she's when
she's promoting her book she's literally
saying if trump wins again it's the end
of democracy this is the the key point
that this makes me think of is like they
run around saying you undermine
democracy all the time they're the ones
this is what they're trying to do there
is an election they didn't like the
result so they weren't about trying to
have done it and yet they get to accuse
of course everyone else it's just like
with with racism they go on calling
everyone racist they're the ones that
finish that but it all works based on
our short attention spans it's like so
you can talk about january 6 forever as
long as you don't remember all of this
stuff that happened before and actually
most people are like most people
especially in the media they don't
remember you know kat i think there was
a high point to all of this and that was
the introduction of the phrase p-tape
yeah yeah cause we could talk about it
now openly
um i was talking about openly and i also
didn't even if it was real i didn't
really have a problem with it
exchange of goods why do i care yeah
exactly
and you have questions you started
talking about p no i don't i was just uh
gonna ask you what your thoughts were
yeah i mean look it's
i think it must be really nice
to be able to be this wrong and this
mean when you are wrong and not even
like feel bad or do any self-examination
um because i do too much
self-examination i think yes you know i
feel i feel i feel bad when i do things
wrong they don't it must be nice yes it
must be nice what about you tyrus
thoughts on this you know with i was
looking i try to look at the whole you
know they say look at the big picture
right and you look at that whole error
of in you know the the dossier and
the mueller report and all the criminals
that were flushed out
but they were all democrats
cuomo avenatti
steele dossier like everybody who came
out to be
heroes yeah were bad guys so
of course the dossier
wasn't real
nothing
through that entire period was real and
that's why they're not going to
apologize because they'll just say well
it's my truth right that's right i saw
it at the time
so exactly
such a specific thing to make but at
least the tape was flushed out i mean we
got to say that's like you know well and
it served their purpose it was able to
diminish a trump presidency that's all
they cared about they've their mission
we now have high inflation yeah
that's literally what it is i'll take a
pee tape over high inflation any day
sometimes i have and tweets yes hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else